naja auf Baustellen gibt es ja oft das
Schild elternhaften für ihre Kinder wer
haftet allerdings für Erwachsene die
sich wie Kinder aufführen oder schlimmer
noch für Erwachsene die andere
Erwachsene wie Kinder behandeln und
damit willkommen auf dem Spielplatz der
Berliner Republik dort grassiert nämlich
neben anderen Viren auch das Virus der
Infantilisierung wir haben Videos auf
denen wir am Beispiel gesehen sogar
selbst die Bundestags Präsidentin Frau
Bars sich also wie eine Comicfigur zum
Affen oder zu essen macht wir haben
Fotos Videos von der jüngsten
Bundestagsabgeordneten Frau fester von
den Grünen die also Tanz werden eben
gesehen die grüne Landtags
Fraktionsvorsitzende Frau Schulze die
also mampfen lachend durch die
fraktionsklausursitzung in Bayern führt
wir haben sogar ein Bundeskanzler der
spricht als wäre der Schiffschaukel
Bremser am Hamburger Hummel wenn er von
Bazooka spricht von Wumms und
Doppelpunkt und gleichzeitig werden die
Bürger von diesen kindlichen Erwachsenen
ihrerseits für Kinder behandelt also wir
haben für 30 milliar mit uns erklärt wie
wir Energie sparen sollen der grüne
Ministerpräsident sagt nimmt doch mal
Lappen vielleicht auch einen trockenen
duschen muss nicht sein also wir haben
leider Gottes beides Politiker die sich
in einer sehr ernsten Lage wie Kinder
verhalten meinen dadurch auch
Sympathiepunkte zu bekommen aber ich
würde sagen wichtiger ist Kompetenz als
diese kindlichen Sympathiepunkte und wir
haben gleichzeitig eine Regierung die
uns alle wie Kinder behandeln will und
mit diesen beiden Form von
Infantilisierung muss Schluss sein ein
Königreich ein Königreich für etwas mehr
Reife
hast mir einmal zusammen wir haben
darüber gesprochen früher gab es Trinker
im Parlament jetzt gibt's Tanzvideos
dann kann man eigentlich sagen na ja was
ist daran so schlimm schlimm ist
zunächst mal ich bin ja gar nichts
verbieten ich bin ja dafür dass die
Leute auch Freude haben bei ihrem Tun
dass sie lachen ich lache auch selber
die Frage ist doch immer in dem Fall ja
nein nein nein ich glaube mich keine
Sorgen
ja aber die Frage ist immer mit wie
kriegt man in die Öffentlichkeit und die
habe ich auch noch ein Rest von Ahnung
was das Hohe Haus so heißt er das Hohe
Haus bedeutet und dann macht dort Frau
Bart irgendwie witzige Figur suchen und
Frau fester mit zwei anderen Jungen
Grünen Bundestagsabgeordneten tanzt
irgendwie herum es wird die Stimme
verfremdet wir müssen nur auch schauen
das ist würdevoll dort wir vertreten
oder die Abgeordneten vertreten das Volk
den souverän in dem sie ihre Macht
verdanken es sind sehr ernste Zeiten wir
müssen direkt uns unterhalten aber doch
nicht bitteschön wie die Kindsköpfe was
hat denn das für eine Folge auch für die
Gesellschaft wenn man sagt an der Spitze
ist es gut ich kindisch zu geben also
praktisch nicht dümmer zu machen als du
bist wir müssen doch nach oben schauen
wir versuchen klug zu sein erwachsen
heiter auch gelassen aber doch nicht als
Kindsköpfe das sind leider Gottes auch
die Grünen nicht nur aber auch die
Grünen fahren mit dabei ich würde sagen
liebe Leute ein bisschen mehr erwachsen
sein im Umgang nach außen zeigen es ist
schön erwachsen zu sein an der Stelle
auch der Kern noch ihre Kritik drin ein
bisschen mehr Kompetenz absolut ja weil
natürlich in dem Moment in dem ich sehr
stark auf eine Emotion emotionale Ebene
agiere auf eine sympathisch wirkende
lustige kickende mampfende Art wie das
vor Schulz vielleicht gemacht hat dann
habe ich natürlich gar keinen Raum in
dem Moment im Kompetenz dieses Kurs zu
finden
eine regt sich auf der andere klatscht
aber es werden ja gewissermaßen Energie
Reserven immer für die Kompetenz
bräuchte abgeräumt wie kann ich jemanden
so wirklich ernst nehmen wenn wir so
jemand dessen Video ich im Kopf habe
nicht mehr rausbekomme der wird mir
jetzt erklären dass er in ganz ganz
ernsten Zeiten wir müssen alle den
Gürtel enger schnallen und danach sehe
ich dann wie er sich irgendwie lustig
macht über die würde die im zugefallen
ist wie gesagt gute Laune heiterkeit ist
nicht verboten aber bitte nicht so
infantil und das Stichwort kompetenziale
checke wir haben eine viele auch die
überhaupt keine Berufserfahrung mehr
haben die nie im Job waren die
vielleicht auch gar nicht studiert haben
diese sofort in die Politik reinrutschen
ist da manchmal zu wenig Kompetenz und
diesen Job auszuüben sehen Sie es auch
ja ich denke das ist schon ein Anrecht
ist zu sagen eine Berufsausbildung ist
was vorteilhaft ist oder ein Studium wir
haben natürlich auch gerade bei den
nicht akademischen Berufen einen Defizit
und jemand der ein Handwerk ausübt als
tierischen Beruf oder in ihrem Handtuch
in ihrer Fraktion ich glaube wir haben
zumindest eine die Handwerk gemacht aber
es ist nicht eine Handwerkerin haben wir
glaube ich nicht das ist richtig ja
so ein Beispiel das ja nicht nur bei den
Grünen so in der Tat was jetzt das
Verkaufen von Politik angeht am Ende
muss jeder seinen Weg selber finden ich
finde ein bisschen Freude und von mir
aus auch tanzen ist okay man muss halt
immer auch den Zeitpunkt für diese
Botschaften überlegen ich selber machst
seit einiger Zeit anders oder vielleicht
ist eigentlich schon länger ja ich bin
sehr langweilig genau
auf Facebook mich entschuldigen keine
Zeit Fotos zu machen ich schreibe jetzt
einfach blind Text rein weil ich finde
dass der Einfluss der sozialen Netzwerke
insgesamt negativ ist auf die Politik
also erst es ist zu viel Inszenierung
und es ist dann in der Tat auch ein
Verlust von Substanz und es werden dann
allerdings auch die Umgangsform in den
sozialen Netzwerken das werden sie auch
alle wissen sind so schlecht geworden in
den Jahren jetzt dass ich langsam nicht
mehr weiß wo befindet sich da eigentlich
dann die Diskurs Ebene
ich habe früher es ist noch jung aber es
sollte man hat doch aufgeschaut nach
Berlin zum Bundestag zum Reichstag das
waren doch also Legenden die dort
arbeiten wir haben unsere Sachen mit
verhandelt und jetzt werde ich
tagtäglich und dass ich suchen würde
aber einfach mal ins Netz gewinnt man
zugeschüttet mit Videos von
Bundestagsabgeordneten die einfach offen
wird es gar nicht so ernst nehmen
genau
[Gelächter]
Repräsentanz des Staates und der
Gesellschaft der wir ja angehören ich
will doch nicht vom kindsköpfen
vertreten werden das kann mir auch
keiner sagen 20-jähr vier oder
22-Jährige jetzt im Bundestag sind
würden für ihre Generation sprechen wenn
sie sich besonders infil geben also es
gibt doch auch ernsthafte 22 und 23
jährigen warum gehen die so stark mit
dieser Message raus haben wir jetzt auch
Emily von uns die jüngste 22 Jahre alt
jetzt Heiko Maas geht raus sie geht rein
sagst du Zara da wird jetzt junge
Generationen abgeholt endlich frischer
Wind ja also ich bin ehrlich gesagt
skeptisch ob jetzt die jungen
Generationen da ihre die meisten
Kompetenz mit reinbringen sollen aber
was interessantes werden wir am Anfang
die alkoholstudie jetzt haben wir diese
infantile
Politiker die eigentlich auch so tiktok
Politik machen und in dieser Social
Media Blase sich irgendwie auch von der
Realität Weg flüchten wollen also sie
tun es auch aber das Gefühl ich habe das
Gefühl die Politiker tun das auf eine
andere Art und Weise sich auch von der
Realität Weg flüchten zu wollen das
sieht man auch dann in der Politik wenn
es heißt wir haben keinen
Kontrollverlust an den Grenzen denn das
heißt wir haben keinen Strom Problem
wenn es heißt es gibt keine
insolvenzelle also diese
realitätslose Politik ist dann am Ende
auch dieses Produkt davon ja Schritte
wie sehen Sie das wir haben gerade
gehört wenig bei den Grünen keine
Handwerker beispielsweise wünschen Sie
sich mehr Pragmatiker mehr Menschen mit
Erfahrung mit Berufserfahrung in der
Politik also erstmal glaube ich das
Politik auch einhandwerk ist das nicht
überall wo ein Hammer in die Hand
genommen wird das Handwerk ja also die
Zunge kann auch sowas wie ein Hammer
sein nicht und dann würde ich mir
wünschen sie haben mir egal also paar
Leute angesprochen nicht für von früher
kennen aber die haben wir ja heute auch
alle vielleicht sehen wir sie so nur
einfach nicht mehr so wen haben Sie da
im Kopf gehen wir heute auch alle
würde ich jetzt gar nicht sagen
deswegen sondern weil mir viel wichtiger
ist das für heute noch eine andere
Politik auf der Straße haben nicht also
wenn sowas wie Luise Neugebauer auf die
Straße geht oder oder gret hat
Luisa Neubauer ja also wir erleben
einfach eine politische Landschaft die
viel breiter geworden ist die sich auch
unterschiedlich darstellt ja was sie mit
Würde des Amtes gerade kommunizieren ist
ja eher etwas was wir aus den 50ern 16
Institution muss eine würde haben als
Demokratie sind Demokraten dann brauche
ich ja auch eine würde sich das ja auch
in Ordnung oder
also ich glaube eine eine lebendige
Demokratie braucht auch Lebendigkeit
wenn die dann manchmal aus dem Raum
schlägt mag das alles sein aber das
würde ich jetzt nicht so als als Engpass
sehen sage ich mal viel schlimmer finde
ich tatsächlich das hast du schon
angesprochen wir kommen in eine Zeit der
Krisen nein wir sind schon mitten in
Zeiten von Krisen das heißt wir brauchen
vielleicht auch Heiterkeit vielleicht
brauchen wir bessere Heiterkeit wir
brauchen klare Sprache aber wir brauchen
keine klare Sprache die mit Würde
daherkommt sondern die mit klarer
Sprache leicht verständlicher Sprache
daher kommt die Leute mitnimmt diese an
Bord holt wenn das mit Lachen passieren
kann ist das Gute ich vermisse mehr
Humor in der Politik also ich könnte mir
also was wir von Joschka Fischer oder
soll ich noch gekannt haben ja also nach
dem Motto mal ein bisschen humorvoll
über die Strecke schlagen das könnte uns
glaube gut tun damit wir auch mal Dampf
ablassen können Humor ist er gerade
Erwachsene das wäre man Kritikpunkt dass
wir nicht bei Humor sind sondern bei
oberflächlich oberflächlicher ulknudelei
und das ist schon ein großer Unterschied
ich bin sehr viel Humor ich bin für Witz
wie gesagt für Heiterkeit Gelassenheit
alles da kann man aber auch streiten ich
mache lieber den trocknet Weinen habe
davon ich hätte lieber nur Eiswein
vielleicht ja und was soll der trocknet
Würzburg
alles angucken kann man ja auch gar
nicht und
deswegen ist es ja immer so eine Frage
die man selber entscheidet ja dagegen
entschieden was geht Ihnen durch den
Kopf wir hatten ja jetzt gerade ein paar
Bilder gezeigt wenn man viele
Parteikolleginnen dabei denken sie dann
oh gott ist das albern oder denken Sie
so neumodische Social Media Zeug ist
irgendwie nicht mein Ding oder denken
sie sollen die mal machen aber ich mache
sie haben sich ja bewusst auch dagegen
entschieden jetzt nicht ja ich habe mich
ich habe früher auch schon Gitarre
gespielt auf Social Media und mal
irgendwie im Wahlkampf was gemacht was
ich ein bisschen lustiger Vater
authentisch ja jetzt machen wir doch mal
so ein tiktok Video bekommen in der Zeit
ich bin jetzt 9 Jahre Bundestag dass das
eine hohe Ernsthaftigkeit braucht in der
Kommunikation und ich lieber dann wenn
ich bei Facebook zum Beispiel schon eh
nur noch die älteren Leute kann man
sagen jemand unterwegs was rein schreibe
was dann 5000 Leute lesen dann bin ich
da stolz drauf und wenn ich ein Bild
habe ist das schön ja aber das ist ja
nicht mein Ziel also ich möchte ja mit
dem Inhalt gesehen werden
nichtsdestotrotz verurteilt dich das
nicht also ich kann nachvollziehen wenn
andere das anders machen ich persönlich
schaue mir das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
kann weil ich interessiere mich nicht
für Instagram groß ich bin da dort aber
ich kommuniziere rein in den Raum ich
nehme da nicht Teil ja ich verstehe halt
nicht ob es nur einmal noch zu sagen
warum eine
Bundestagspräsidentin wie Frau Bars es
ist glaube die Nummer zwei oder drei im
Staat Nummer drei glaube ich was die
meint ihrem Amt ihrer Wahrnehmung ihrer
Partei sich selbst gut zu tun wenn Sie
sich hier zum backspanie macht bei einem
Instagram oder Tiki wieder
zurückgenommen danach so ein Fehler aber
was denkt man denn in dem Moment wo man
sagt das mache ich das ist gut es ist
Zeit in irgendeiner Weise auf mein Konto
auf mein Amt auf mich persönlich an das
verstehe ich glaube es gibt ja so eine
Diskussion dass man die jungen Menschen
erreichen kann nur mit solchen Bildern
das ist aber die Frage ob das nicht eine
junge Generation ist zu sagen die
schauen sich jetzt nur tiktok Videos an
wo Leute irgendwelche Kunststücke
aufführen und dessen das ist dann
Politik aber Ehrlichkeit halber ein Teil
davon erreichen natürlich auch über
solche Formate das ist auch egal die
Kritik ist ja auch wichtig wir brauchen
Mut zum Experiment Experiment ja ja auf
der anderen Seite auch Kritik an der
misslungen in Experiment unterschätzen
die Politiker vielleicht da manchmal
auch die Wählerinnen und Wähler also
dass man mit gixie gaxi so würden sie es
wahrscheinlich nennen wirklich jemanden
erreichen kann überzeugen kann das geht
natürlich schon um Aufmerksamkeit auch
um Leute zu erreichen die Frage ist wie
weit wie weit gehe ich und wen erreiche
ich damit und möchte ich bestimmte
sogenannte Politik für eine Zielgruppen
erreichen
also man ist wirklich Politik also ich
aber es ist ja eigentlich nur
Unterhaltung also machen jetzt die
Politiker Unterhaltung also dafür haben
wir sie glaube ich nicht gewählt und
gerade die großen Parteien sollten sich
eigentlich auf ernste Themen
konzentrieren wo wir gerade auch gesagt
haben was für Krisenzeiten wir leben und
ich finde das auch ganz interessant die
Grünen sind ja eigentlich so die
moralisch zu Partei in den Bundestag was
auch gar nicht so schlecht ist bei
vielen Themen gerade wenn z.B um Iran
geht aber wenn es dann um tiktok geht ja
also wo wir sagen das ist eigentlich
eine Überwachungstechnik gibt es am
meisten von China dann ist es dann
plötzlich egal ob wir da gerade eine
Kurve Diktatur herrscht und Menschen in
einer Art von Konzentrationslager drin
sind also da ist dann die Moral auf
einmal nicht da und dann ist man dort
kindisch auf einer
china-app also nicht zusammen gesprochen
was man tatsächlich sehen muss weil sie
jetzt China sprechen weil wer sich so
auf Medien zeigt muss natürlich also
wenn ich mir dann überlege jetzt kommt
nur dieses Bild vielleicht in Chile
plötzlich auf dem Flimmerkasten guck mal
was in Deutschland los ist wir gewinnen
kann
liebe Leute dann wird schon schwierig ne
also das will man dann vielleicht auch
nicht also wir leben heute in einer in
einer Medienwelt wo es viele kaum noch
kontrollierbarer Kanäle gibt und dann
muss man natürlich schon gucken mit
welchem Content völlig den kann Ausland
über uns wirklich jetzt unseren Beitrag
einmal quält die Welt verteilen auf den
deutschen kannst du gar nicht so
schlecht gehen
Zeit haben offenbar haben die dort noch
furchtbar viel Spaß und gar nicht allzu
große Probleme das muss dieser spezielle
deutsche Humor sein sonst keiner
versteht ich denke das wird man da
denken ähm ich würde es auch nicht jedes
einzelne zu hoch jetzt aber wird die
Grundtendenz ist einfach dass wir Gefahr
laufen ich habe darüber ja auch ein Buch
geschrieben dass wir Gefahr laufen nicht
das reife sondern das unreife aus Podest
zu stellen also der gute Mensch ist der
der möglichst ungefiltert seine
Emotionen raus lässt der kindisch ist
der ist nicht reflektiert der schnell
beleidigt ist stell Emotion von anderen
provoziert aufnimmt und und auch wieder
herstellt und das finde ich ist haben
wir als Gesellschaft eine Gefahr wenn
wir sagen das reife ist nur des
saturiert das wollen wir gar nicht das
ist irgendwie würdig es ist verstauen
genau und stattdessen einfach emotional
raushauen Emotionen hervorrufen das Kind
gewissermaßen auch immer Erwachsenen zum
Vorbild erklären als gesellschaftliches
Leitbild habe ich damit ein großes
Problem gar nicht so dass das so
wertgeschätzt wird man kann ja auch zur
Schulklassen gehen oder in soziale
Einrichtungen mache ich oft und dann die
Schülerinnen und Schüler die wollen auch
eine ruhige Sprache und die wollen es
nicht dass ich vor den Kunststück
aufführe also es ist vielleicht auch ein
falsches Bild einfach von irgendeine
also name
oder Sie sprechen an mit ja sowas an wie
eine Kultur der würde
und dann würde ich aber sagen dazu
gehört aber auch eine würdevolle
Willkommenskultur und die haben sie
vorhin eher in Frage gestellt wir
sollten nicht jeden ins Land
dareinlassen aber menschlicher aber
Menschenwürde okay dann können Sie das
jetzt vielleicht habe ich verstanden
[Gelächter]
Kultur die angemessen also wir brauchen
genau
nicht jeder Mensch der auf welchen
Pfaden auch immer nach Deutschland kommt
tut uns gut
drauf dass man nicht sagt jeder einzelne
ist automatisch weil aus einem fremder
muss ein bisschen arbeiten dass diese
binden sich durchsetzt auch in den
Parteiprogramm und reden würdevoll heißt
natürlich jeden Menschen seine
unfallierbare Würde zugestehen und auch
wer zu schätzen es ist doch völlig klar
aber es heißt nicht die Augen
verschließen vor Problemen die uns auch
unter dem Überschrift Willkommenskultur
teilweise teilweise teilweise ich sag
noch mal teilweise behauptet werden